okay thank you thanks again for inviting
me to this second workshop a a little
bit less sick than last time so
hopefully I'll be able to give a proper
talk this is a joint work with Colleen
Sandin as a student at Princeton and
I'll talk about the recovering
communities in the block model the paper
has been posted two weeks ago on archive
and I'll start by explaining what
community detection is so the the
problem is you're given a graph network
just a bunch of dots that are either
connected or not and you try to identify
a partition of the graph into subgroups
that are alike
so alike could mean that they are more
densely connected like in this figure
there are clearly five groups that are
much more densely connected with only
few connection across them and
communities are not necessarily denser
groups it could be that the relationship
is this assortative that means you
connect more with people in the other
community that could be Facebook in the
early years with males and females
genders and so there's all sort of
structures but the common one is the one
of assertive connection which is called
clusters so the animation is due to
student Joey opera and Princeton who
spend a few nights on this I think so
I'll play it again this is if you were
not to do the right coaster and if you
just do an arbitrary partition of the
nodes you would get something which is
like junk see tons of connections and no
structure but there's only one here
which is nice it's the proper partition
I'll give you the movie true yeah I
should this is Joelle Pereira that's me
let me write it down alright yeah you
got something yeah yeah I gave you some
chocolates we started so applications of
committed actions they're pretty broad
it the field exploded with social
networks that's one of the first thing
you want to know about networks are
community structures biological networks
protein to protein interactions there
was a talk just before but Gina networks
tumour a classification clustering was
used excessively in these areas
communication networks Bell Labs is
interested this is a call graph people
talking to each other in an internetwork
communication people are interested in
five gene understanding how to
distribute information more efficiently
by using the underlying social structure
of the network it's also applied to
these are problems where the network is
in a sense natural then there's a whole
bunch of applications where the network
is engineer from data sets for example
you have a collection of databases of
images and you connect to images if they
share some common features that gives
you graphs of similar similarities and
then you try to detect clusters or
commit in the graph segmentation
recommendations systematize meant
information retrieval broadly speaking
wherever you have some data sets of
similarities and you try to understand
groups of noted are alike you rely on
these methods so the stochastic Bach
model is a network model with so it's a
random graph model with a cluster
structure and this is the model I used
this notation SVM with three parameters
n P and Q and is the number of vertices
in the graph P is a probability probably
vector the dimension of the vector K is
the number of community
that you're you have in your model and P
I is the relative size of community I so
this is a for example for communities of
different sizes this is there's roughly
n times P 1 nodes in community 1 and
times P to note in community to et
cetera
capital P I'm going to use for the
diagonal matrix or you put those this
vector P on the diagonal and the third
parameter here in the model is Q it's a
symmetric matrix with entries in 0 1 and
it tells you how a node in committee inj
connect that's the probability Q I J
that D connects so here is all the
possible connections actually Q 1 1
inside Q want to be between 1 and 2 etc
so since the workshop is about
information theory I see this model as
the DNC of clustering DNC for those of
you or not information theories is the
discrete memoryless channel it's a it's
a nice and reasonable model for
committee detection nice in the sense
that as we will see there are very nice
phase transition phenomena like the
capacity type of results that gives you
a good way to benchmark algorithm with a
clear line of sight it's reasonable in
the sense that it's of course a model so
it's not exactly realistic but it fits
pretty well some cases of data and also
just like the DMC is not a real model
for communication there's always memory
and things like that but out of this
model you can extend it with some
variants with overlapping communities
and things like that that actually
become really practical so it's a good
model I think now just to see if we are
ok with the parameters this is the quiz
if I notice in committee I how many
neighbors that he'd have an expectation
in community J the options okay so I
didn't have idea is through quiz for me
I don't have to be multiple choice but I
should have put multiple choice so
there's one choice I offer you it's the
answer it's a it's that's the number of
nodes that they are in community J's and
then you connect each of them is
probably Qi Chi that's an expectation
how many you have so that's a matrix
which is going to show up a few times
remember this is a diagonal matrix of
the P is times Q that matrix if you look
at column column I it tells you the
community profile what a node sees like
in its neighborhood how many nodes in
each community does an expectation all
right so the problem is when and how can
we recover the clusters from the graph
drawn from this model when means for
which P and Q you can solve the problem
and it's going to be with high
probability when n tends to infinity of
course if Q for example is a matrix
where all the entries are the same then
you are you have an erdos-renyi model
because there's no trace of the
community is everybody connects in the
same way so it's clearly impossible to
find the clusters but we would like to
understand what measure of discrepancy
of the queue entries is allowing you to
tell when you can or not
cluster and if this depends probably
also on this piece and now is also about
efficiency of the algorithm whether we
can solve it efficiently or information
directly only so the next slides are
about the first to warm up the case of
two symmetric communities which is
already pretty hard and got a lot of
work on then new results about partial
and exact recovery in the general SVM
and that's the model I defined just
before and I'll motivate and try to
explain how I think this is really
closely related to the child coding
theorem and then since there's big data
in the title of the workshop I'll try to
show you at least one case of how this
fits on real data so the model with two
symmetric community is also called the
planting bisection model it's very
simple you have two groups the
probability the relative size are half
so to group 4 of roughly and over 2
nodes and you connect with probability
little P inside the groups for both
groups and little Q across now you ask
if you take a graph like that you raise
those colors you shuffle it I give it to
you can you recover
groups so there's a bit of history on
this model it was defined in 83 and
there's been a lot of work this is just
a partial list mixture of computer
scientists mathematicians and
statisticians that's recovery means that
you really try to recover the cluster so
you denote labels as to be correct with
asymptotically when n tends to infinity
all notes we labels must be correctly
found and the the results looked pretty
much all like this how close can pin Q
be so that you can solve the problem as
we said before P is equal to Y a here
the property is of the over the drawing
of the random graph this is all X and
hat as in to be equal to X n so all
that's exactly correct and the full
thing and it looks like this how close
can pin Q be so that you can solve this
problem if P is equal to Q we know it's
not possible so you'd like it to be as
small as possible and the approach is
basically algorithmic people come with a
new idea of an algorithm they try it and
they see what they get then there's been
a new line of work that started around
2010 for the past 5 years where people
have changed the figure of Merit instead
of recovery they looked at detection
this means that you only ask for a
reconstruction of the nodes that is
positively correlated the other extreme
instead of recovering the full
partition you just want something that
has a numbing distortion there's a
little bit better than half as synthetic
lis where half is what you get with a
random uniform gas if you don't even
look at the graph you just flip back on
you get 50% right you want to beat that
ascetically so this what happened here
is that this group of people Dessau
across Cameron's Devorah we came up with
a very precise and very nice picture for
this model of detection in the symmetric
case based on statistical physics
arguments non rigorous but the result is
like this that the conjecture that if P
and Q are scaling like a constant by n
with different constant a and B then you
can detect if and only if you have this
nice equation so that's pretty amazing
because it's an if and only if and also
they have an explicit formula so it took
a bit of work to actually prove that
statement this was done
Julian Mussolini man sly last year and
one way to interpret the result is this
equation you can rewrite it like this
that's another way to rewrite this
equation this thing here that's a 1 this
thing here is what you need to have a
giant component in your network and you
know you need a giant for at least
hoping for the detection and what this
is somehow an over sampling you need to
to be able to detect you need more than
the giant so at that time I was reading
those paper I thought this looks like an
extension of the giant but for recovery
we also know that we need the graph to
be at least connected which is more than
giant which happens in a logarithmic
degree regime so why would there not be
another facial addition for recovery and
in fact this takes place we could show
it last year if you take P and Q that
scales with an additional log in factor
then you can recover the clusters if and
only if you have this equation and this
becomes the oversampling that you need
in order to recover as opposed to just
having connectivity so this improves the
bound that that were there before but it
also gives the sufficient a necessary
condition so now there's another work by
Muslim and slide that obtain the same
result pretty much shortly after this in
an independent work where they have more
general general results for a and B that
can depend on n as long as they are that
big theta of 1 so in both cases we have
algorithms that achieve the threshold so
on information technically this is the
limit and you can achieve it all the way
down to the limit we have two algorithm
in our paper one is an SDP relaxation so
I'll just say a few words because it
will connects to the neck next talk the
maximum likelihood estimator of the
clusters from the graph is the mean
bisection you are trained to look for a
partition of the nodes in two groups
with the least amount of edges across
the two groups
that's np-hard because you want the
groups to have same size to be balanced
so what you can do is you can write it
with an SDP relaxation and to ensure
that the SDP gets you the ground truth
you come out you end up with a probably
on a random matrix a random laplacian of
the stochastic block model and you want
to show that the spectral norm of that
matrix is a is large enough so that you
get that the SDP works and if you do in
the paper originally here we use
matrix Bernstein to show the the the
spectral norm is bounded in a certain
way and this is a little bit loose it's
roughly off by a factor too and there
has been two works that allowed to
extend it one is using the more powerful
bound on that Raman we'll talk about in
the next talk
and then also recently he on with Bruce
Hayek and jiaming zoo obtained also that
removed the constant by using as it was
the name of the bound Z the inner okay
sorry
okay so what's interesting is that it's
not clear at all what happens for
multiple communities in fact for
detection its contacted at studying when
you have five communities or more you
know longer I can achieve the threshold
which is information Tariq we don't know
what the threshold is but with numerical
experiments people have conjecture that
there's a gap between what you can do
information technically and efficiently
and for recovery there is no explicit
contribute that we are made in our
papers so I'll address this question
today so how much is how much time did I
take so far
so before I tell you the results I'll
tell you about why I think this is very
closely related to coding theory and
particular the channel coding theorem so
in coding what we want is to we have n
information bits that we want to
transmit there's a noisy channel of
course we cannot transmit them there the
the end of them we cannot get them if we
just pass them through directly the
channel because this is noisy but if we
embed them into a longer code word
adding redundancy then we can hope to
recover the end bits from capital and
transmitted bits and Shannon told us
that you can actually solve the problem
with a ratio between the number of
transmitted information and transmitted
bits that is constant the rate of the
code so if the noise is let's see a
binary symmetric channel that means you
flip 0 to 1 with probability epsilon and
it's symmetric then as long as the rate
is less than this epsilon log 1 over
Epsilon except right then you can
actually solve that problem you can
decode reliably those bits from there so
clustering this model is can be
interpreted that way you have an
information bits these are the community
assignment of the N people in the graph
yes thank you Thanks it's a bit
embarrassing I cannot write here I think
but so so do you have again an
information bits that's your community
assignment and people each you look at
each pair of nodes in your graph and
then depending on whether those nodes
have the same level or not you put an
edge with different probabilities so in
the case of the block model in the
logarithmic regime this will be your
channel if they are in the same group so
you look atlet's being in the same group
or not is that looking at the XOR so
that's in fact a linear code and then if
they're in the same group you put an
edge with probably a log n by N and
different group with the B log n by n
that's your channel so it's exactly a
special structure codes on a special
Channel and the rate is fixed that's the
difference with channel coding it's not
variable it's 2 by n because there's n
choose 2 possible edges you can actually
make the model different where there you
have measurements about the interactions
of people with some
in which case the analogy becomes very
precise with the channel coding theorem
but let's stick with a fixed rate for
now and then what we have is this
property here which is that again you
can do reliable communication I don't
know if you see it but reliable
communication is exactly clustering
because decoding so these guys here are
the graph each variable is whether there
is an edge or not between a pair of
nodes so that's the graph and these are
the community assignment decoding for
this from this is exactly reliable
communication so you can solve reliable
communication if and only if you have
this phase notation so write this
equation here that's 1 instead of read
because we are at the fixed rate so now
in Shannon's theorem we have a much more
general formula it's not just for the
binary symmetric channel as long as you
have it doesn't have to be bits it could
be Curie bits with some distribution and
an arbitrary channel here you can
succeed if the rate is below this
maximum of the mutual information where
the mutual information is expressed in
terms of the KL divergence so the
question I was wondering is is there
such a formula for commitee detection if
you don't have bits but you have
arbitrary number of communities that
means these are curie bits if you have
an arbitrary channel which is the this q
that we had in the previous slides is
there again a general formula and what
would be the expression for J so the
result is as follows if you're looking
at the regime where you have logarithmic
degree that's where you need to operate
to get for recovery then you can in fact
solve recovery if and only if this
expression is more than 1 so that's your
GP q and what is D plus D plus is this
notion of distance between two measure
is the sum over of the convex sum here
so like a arithmetic mixture - the
geometric mixture and then you sum over
all components and maximize over T so
that's a that seems to be a pretty fun
object how does it relate to object that
we know so I'll call this object without
the maximization dt of mu and nu so
first of all it's a net divergence so
that Assad was really cool because it's
the same family of divergence and the KL
divergence that we have for channel
coding so the clustering capacity is
also using F diversion that Xi's are
defined
in his a paper in the 60s I don't think
it had an operational meaning up to this
result so it's actually not an F
divergence if you maximize over T but if
you just plug half here then is the
Ehlinger their divergence or distance in
fact the maximum is the maximization
over T is at half for the symmetric
block model in which case you recover
the result we had before
this equation here is the same as this
is the rewriting this in the symmetric
case and this is exactly the same as a
plus B by 2 more than one plus square
root of a B but if you are not in the
symmetric case then the Maximizer may
not be half so it may not be the return
Avenger distance then it's going to be
something which is a jurisdiction of the
Chernoff divergence so if you look at
this object here with the summation and
with the max you just put a log on top
then this is called a turn of divergence
but in our case mu and nu are not
necessarily per distribution so this sum
is under c1o after array so in other
words this is a jurisdiction of both
Ehlinger divergence and the Chernoff
divergence so we call it in the paper
the Chernoff arranger divergence that's
what it's causes that and the plus could
be for identify that you maximize or for
the fact that this is the swiss flag for
community AlphaTech this was for qrg non
zero let me skip this so now what can
you do algorithmically so we have an
algorithm which we call degree profiling
that she's a threshold and not only is
efficient but it's actually quasi linear
time so that means complexity is o to
the N 1 plus epsilon for all epsilon
positive for epsilon as small as you
want as many is positive so here I
should see a collie need an amazing work
getting this quasi linear time that's
pretty hard heretic is really a lot of
effort time so showing that this was
achievable
efficiently is not easy but making it
quasi dinner was really a lot of
dedicated work so the conclusion is that
for recovery in after detection you can
actually solve the problem whenever it
is information that is solvable you can
show you solve it efficiently there's no
gap in that case
it's an information terrain complexity
so quickly three minutes so quickly
sometimes you you don't want to ask can
you recover exactly all the committee's
but you could could ask the question
which community can you recover so here
is how you solve the problem you you do
an embedding of the communities you you
embed you represent them as the ice
column of the matrix PQ I call this a
local committee profile this is a vector
in R to the power of K and then you try
to partition to pack those points in a
way that the the CH divergence between
any two points is more than one and this
is the finest partition you can get the
largest number of groups you can obtain
with this property is what you can
recover these guys you must confuse them
but otherwise these subgroups you can
recover okay so the proof idea it's the
message here is the following instead of
sweating to get to the actual threshold
in one shot with one algorithm it turns
out to be easier to first get 99% and
then switchgear and use a different
method to finish up the problem it's
more efficient so for that you need to
know how to solve partial recovery
getting not everything but a constant
fraction and that's what I'm gonna skip
and here is the algorithm I it works you
take your network you split it into two
networks
that's my last line and what oh yeah I'm
skipping reader hahaha I have to choose
other the proof okay maybe we should you
you want the real data instead
okay so I'll skip the proof think I'm
using my last minute with the be baby
so I'll do born oh you speak a network
into two groups on one group you use
partial recovery to get almost
everything and then you're left with an
iPod SS testing problem you look at the
node and you say is it more likely to be
in this cluster to be moving the other
clusters and for that you have to
compare two Poisson distributions turns
out that the error rate of the deposits
is the same problem makes the CH
divergence come out that was very quick
summary that's how you you have that
thing that shows up for the data we took
the blog networks it's like about about
fifteen hundred blogs all you know is
which blocks puts a link to another blog
you have any other informations and you
try to reconstruct which one is a right
or left leaning and I just out of
curiosity we plotted we see what kind of
parameters we would get if this was from
a stochastic block model these two
groups we get those numbers and this is
just above what the threshold should be
this is the square root of two so in
theory if this where you're not in the
limit of n goes to infinity but your n
is 1500 but in theory if the if the
model were to be feeling well here you
should be able to recover most of it and
we get 95% which is pretty good with our
algorithm thank you advertisement
there's a tutorial on information train
machine learning and SAT if you
interested and then I'll stop here
so how do you get those numbers you just
count the number of edges there's two
ways one is to use the fact that we know
the ground truth because people have
checked the blogs and you can take the
ground choose to compute them yeah at
Sandburg this is all empirical averages
so I'm saying either you in that case we
knew the ground truth so you can
actually you know the two groups so you
can compute those partners but in
general you can also use the algorithm
to cluster and then use the the costume
that you have from the algorithm and
then compute those parameters and see if
they satisfy the equation if they don't
and you know you have in a sense you
have done some nonsense because you if
the model was correct you could not have
recovered something meaningful this no
no no